Film Courage: You have two movies coming out
that star Bruce Willis. How did this happen?
Matt Eskandari, Writer/Director/Producer:
Sometimes when people ask me you just did
two movies with Bruce Willis starring and they
think it just happened overnight or just one of
those things that kind of hit but as a filmmaker
I’ve been grinding and doing it for more than
a decade. I went to film school awhile ago,
I’ve been telling stories, writing scripts,
making movies. So to some people it feels almost
like this overnight thing but no, I’ve been
at this for awhile and it’s taken
awhile to get to that point where
my work is established enough where people will
come to me like Oh we want you to direct this
film or we’ve seen your work and we feel like
your style (your vision) would really fit into
the content that we’re creating. That’s
how those films came about is I did several
independent films that got a lot of buzz (a lot of
attention) and they attracted producers were like
Oh hey we’re doing these other movies, are you
interested? We’ve love to hear your take on them
and it’s a process. It’s like a job interview,
right? You go in there and read the script
and come up with your vision for how
you think that film should be directed.
Film Courage: Can we hear more about this pitch?
Matt: Yes. As a director when
you’re going to direct a script from
another writer or a studio project
or a production company has,
you have a certain freedom to kind of
read the script and come up with your
vision for it and that includes everything from
a lookbook to cast to how you think the world
is designed and looked and the visuals and
everything just every little detail that
you can go in there with describing how you think
that film should be made and it’s everything from
we’re going to use a lot of steadicam and we’re
going to use handheld, we’re going to use these
kind of lenses, we are going to develop this sort
of arc with the characters and it’s going in there
with a confident vision of how you think that film
should be translated from the script to the screen
and that’s really what you’re doing as a director
when you read someone else’s script. You’re taking
that and sort of deciphering how you think
the best version of that film should be made.
Film Courage: How was it to have this production
company was it that worked with Bruce or
knew…there was another company that knew the
company that worked with him…approach you and
did you feel like you were validated like
Okay now this is a real filmmaking thing?
Matt: Yes, I definitely feel like it was being
able to getting approached to direct a script from
another writer that has A-list talent like Bruce
Willis attached is definitely sort of a Oh…Whoah!
This is finally a little validation of my work
as a filmmaker that people are trusting me with
telling this story. So it definitely elevated
the level of okay the stakes are really high on
this one. I really need to step it up and make
sure that I bring it 100 percent of my passion
and all the knowledge and experience that I’ve
learned as a filmmaker (an independent filmmaker)
for the last decade about okay how do you tell an
interesting story? How do you incorporate elements
of indie filmmaking which is kind of like that
fast-paced, quick, shooting style into a project
where I have a little bit more money to play with
but knowing that it doesn’t mean that you can get
wild with it right? There’s still those parameters
of it’s got to come in under schedule, under
budget and you want to be able to deliver the film
so that people are always asking for the next one.
Film Courage: Sorry…did they sign
on for both movies or was it one?
Matt: No, you do one and then once you…and
that’s part of the experience right?
That’s one of the lessons that you learn
as a filmmaker throughout your career and
I’ve said it time and time again is work
leads to more work. So you do a project,
you write a script for someone and then they
are like Oh hey we’re looking for a director to
direct this other project that we have, we really
liked your script Matt and that film that you did,
would you like to read this script and give us
your take on the project. So that’s one of those
things that both as a filmmaker and everyone in
the industry when you work with a DP, he’ll make
a film, he might meet with a producer who will
hire him on a film that he ends up directing
or you work with an actor and the film might turn
out to be really bad but that actor was really
incredible in the film so you end up hiring him
again on a different film. That’s really so much
of this industry and so much of my career as a
filmmaker has been just one project leading to
the next in terms of the relationships within
that project and the people you meet and the
friends you make and the collaborations
that happen leading to the next thing.
Film Courage: What was the emotion like when you
found out that you got the…was it the first one?
Matt: Yes, definitely the emotion that I
felt as soon as I realized I was going to be
directing this film with Bruce Willis was a lot
of excitement. I was just kind of like Whoah! I
better step it up, you know what I mean? I can’t
mess this up. I’ve got to do the best I can so
it was sort of like this nervousness mixed with
motivation, drive, more dedication. Like okay
I’ve got to step it up and do what I can to tell
the best story possible and direct the best film
possible within the constraints that I’ve been
given. For me I’ve learned to have more of a stoic
reaction in my career to things and I think
that is what has enabled me to have a sustained
career is when bad things happen you have to
be able to look at it from a stoic mentality
of okay…that’s bad but we’re going to keep going
and then when something really amazing happens
like you’re going to get to do or you’ve got
this cool thing or whatever…great, I love that,
that’s good, let’s keep going, let’s keep moving.
So it’s having that balance where you can kind of
not let it take you in either one direction or
another is one of those things that I’ve learned
earlier on just reading about stoic philosophy
and how stoicism helps people in their careers
and it’s something that goes back to ancient Rome
and it’s just something that I’ve learned and even
on set as a director I try to have that sort of
stoic mentality on set because if you have that
confidence and that sort of don’t let the little
things that are going on on set sort of drive you
crazy because they will. If you let either the
highs or the lows hit you then you will lose
that sort of control and you won’t be able to just
go into it confident, almost like a chess match.
Just go in there with confidence knowing that
as things hit you, you can just keep going, take
the hit or then something great happens and then
okay this is great, enjoy that little second of it
and then just keep going. Don’t let that thing
kind of…don’t ride that high to the point where
you forget what’s in the present, what’s
in the moment, what’s happening now.
That’s really been my best bit of advice is to
internalize that stoic philosophy in your career.
Questions for the viewers:
If you could work with one
movie star, who would it be?